The details of this case are very difficult to hear. Extreme child abuse and child murder are involved. This one won't be for everybody. There are far more audio clips than narration in this episode. It is a one-off and won't be a regular thing in the future. The courtroom confession is detailed and horrific. Listener discretion is advised. Calling case number 1556881, the people of the state of Michigan versus Michelle, Angela
本案的细节非常令人难以接受。涉及极端的虐待儿童和杀害儿童行为。本期内容并不适合所有人。本集节目中音频片段远多于叙述。这是一次性的特别节目，未来不会成为常态。法庭上的供词详细且骇人听闻。建议听众谨慎收听。传唤案件编号1556881，密歇根州诉米歇尔·安吉拉（Michelle Angela）案。
Blair. Ms. Blair is charged in this case, count one, child abuse, first degree. Felony, life or any term of years. Count two, child abuse, first degree. Felony, life or any term of years. Count three, child abuse, first degree. Felony, life or any term of years. Count four, child abuse, first degree.
布莱尔（Blair）。布莱尔女士在本案中被控第一项罪名：一级虐待儿童。重罪，刑期为终身监禁或任何年限。第二项罪名：一级虐待儿童。重罪，刑期为终身监禁或任何年限。第三项罪名：一级虐待儿童。重罪，刑期为终身监禁或任何年限。第四项罪名：一级虐待儿童。
Life or any term of years. Count five, child abuse, first degree, committed in the presence of another child. Felony, life or any term of years. Can I get your name please? Sure. Thank you. This story takes place in Detroit, Michigan, at Martin Luther King Homes,
刑期为终身监禁或任何年限。第五项罪名：在另一名儿童在场的情况下实施一级虐待儿童。重罪，刑期为终身监禁或任何年限。请问能告诉我你的名字吗？当然。谢谢。这个故事发生在密歇根州底特律的马丁·路德·金家园（Martin Luther King Homes）。
a low-income public housing complex containing 312 units, located on St. Auburn Street. At 11.30am on Tuesday the 24th of March 2015, an eviction crew from the Wayne County Sheriff's Office attended unit 804 in the Martin Luther King complex. The bailiffs were there to evict the tenant, Michelle Blair, who lived there with her four children.
这是一个位于圣奥本街（St. Auburn Street）、包含312个单元的低收入公共住房小区。2015年3月24日星期二上午11点30分，韦恩县治安官办公室的驱逐小组前往马丁·路德·金小区的804单元。法警此行的目的是驱逐租户米歇尔·布莱尔，她和她的四个孩子住在这里。
Her two daughters aged 17 and 13, and her two sons aged 9 and 8. Michelle was described as a nice, friendly person. Her kids were described as polite and respectful. Sometime around 2012, Michelle had pulled all four of her kids out of school, opting to homeschool them instead. It was around 2014 when neighbors started to notice
她的两个女儿分别17岁和13岁，两个儿子分别9岁和8岁。米歇尔被描述为一个友善、友好的人。她的孩子们被描述为有礼貌且懂事。大约在2012年，米歇尔让四个孩子全部退学，转而选择在家教育他们。大约在2014年，邻居们开始注意到
that they hadn't seen Michelle's 13-year-old daughter, Stony Blair, or her 9-year-old son, Stephen Berry, for a while. Michelle explained that they had been spending a lot of time with an auntie, and that when they were back at home, they didn't really like going out and being around people. They preferred to stay inside. Michelle had been living at a unit for the last 10 years. She was unemployed, receiving a government benefit.
他们已经有一段时间没见过米歇尔13岁的女儿斯托尼·布莱尔（Stony Blair）或她9岁的儿子斯蒂芬·贝里（Stephen Berry）了。米歇尔解释说，他们一直在姨妈家待很长时间，而且当他们回到家时，他们不太喜欢出门或与人接触。他们更喜欢待在室内。米歇尔在那个单元住了10年。她失业了，靠政府救济金生活。
She had money issues, and she hadn't paid her rent. That's why she was being evicted. She owed $2,206. Michelle knew she was getting evicted. She had been served the notice and had seen the dumpsters delivered out the front, where the eviction crew planned to throw all of the stuff. Michelle didn't really want to be there
她有经济问题，而且一直没交房租。这就是她被驱逐的原因。她欠了2206美元。米歇尔知道自己要被驱逐了。她收到了通知，也看到了放在门前的垃圾箱，驱逐小组计划把所有的东西都扔进去。米歇尔其实不想待在那里，
when the eviction crew arrived, so she arranged to stay with a friend, who also lived in the same housing complex. She took her eldest daughter and her youngest son with her to her friend's house, explaining that her other two children were with their aunt. The eviction crew arrived and knocked on Michelle's door. They got no answer. So they forced entry and started the eviction process.
当驱逐小组到达时，所以她安排住在同一个小区的一位朋友家里。她带着大女儿和小儿子去了朋友家，解释说另外两个孩子和他们的姨妈在一起。驱逐小组到达并敲了米歇尔的门。他们没有得到回应。于是他们强行进入并开始了驱逐程序。
They were met with a disgraceful mess of a unit, with rubbish and food scraps all over the floor, items of clothing and other junk thrown around everywhere. The conditions were described as barely liveable. The eviction crew got to work clearing out the furniture of the house, and they came across a chest freezer. They opened it up to see what was inside. 1130,
他们看到的是一个极其肮脏的单元，地板上到处都是垃圾和食物残渣，衣物和其他杂物随处乱扔。居住条件被描述为几乎无法生存。驱逐小组开始清理屋内的家具，他们发现了一个卧式冷柜。他们打开它看看里面有什么。11点30分，
7th precinct, received a call, officer of the same reception, called Mabela, who was in this complex amount of cleaning homes, conducting an eviction. And it was during that eviction process that they discovered two young children
第七分局接到一个电话，同一接待处的警官，被称为马贝拉（Mabela）的人，当时正在这个小区进行驱逐工作。正是在驱逐过程中，他们发现了两个年幼的孩子
in a freezer. Further investigation revealed that it appeared to be to a male, who we're saying is approximately 11 years old, and a female 14 years old inside of a plastic bag, appeared to be frozen. The eviction crew opened the chest freezer and located the frozen body
在冷柜里。进一步调查显示，其中一名似乎是男性，我们称其大约11岁，另一名是女性，14岁，装在塑料袋里，看起来像是被冻住了。驱逐小组打开了卧式冷柜，发现了
of Mitchell's 13-year-old daughter, Stony Blair. That's when they called 911. It wasn't until shortly after that they realised there was a second body underneath, Mitchell's 9-year-old son, Stephen Berry. Mitchell Blair was also known by her nickname, Angel, described as a nice, friendly person by her neighbours. Her Facebook profile read,
米歇尔13岁女儿斯托尼·布莱尔的冰冻尸体。就在那时，他们拨打了911。不久之后，他们才意识到下面还有第二具尸体，是米歇尔9岁的儿子斯蒂芬·贝里。米歇尔·布莱尔也被称为“天使”（Angel），邻居们形容她是一个友善、友好的人。她的Facebook个人资料写着：
Loyal to My Babies, and there is no greater blessing than being called a mum. Mitchell Blair had some serious questions to answer, and it didn't take long for police to catch up with her. We were fortunate yesterday that a member of our community stopped our investigators
“忠于我的宝贝们，被称为妈妈是最大的福分。”米歇尔·布莱尔有一些严重的问题需要回答，警方没过多久就找到了她。我们昨天很幸运，社区的一位成员拦住了我们的调查人员，
and led us to the location where we found and arrested the mother of the two children found dead in her apartment. Our homicide team continues to work diligently to bring some closure to both family and their friends. The medical examiner will be performing autopsies in the next day
并带我们找到了那个位置，我们在那里发现了并逮捕了在公寓中被发现死亡的两名孩子的母亲。我们的凶杀案调查组继续努力工作，以给家人和朋友一个交代。法医将在接下来的一天进行尸检，
and at that time, we will know the cause of death of these two children. As you can imagine, this is a very complex case. While we all understand your desire and the desire to know more about what happened in the home, I will ask you to be mindful of the two children who are also in the home that are still alive.
届时我们将知道这两个孩子的死因。正如你们所能想象的，这是一个非常复杂的案件。虽然我们都理解你们渴望了解家中发生了什么，但我请求你们也要考虑到家中另外两个仍然活着的孩子。
Her two surviving children were taken into protective custody while police got to work trying to find out what happened. A background check showed that between the years 2002 and 2005, Mitchell Blair had been investigated on two separate occasions for allegations of child abuse. The abuse claims were substantiated.
她的两个幸存子女被送往保护性监护，同时警方开始努力查明发生了什么。背景调查显示，在2002年至2005年间，米歇尔·布莱尔曾因虐待儿童的指控受到过两次调查。虐待指控均被证实。
Her punishment was counselling. She was allowed to keep custody of her children. As part of the investigation, Mitchell's surviving children were interviewed. What they detailed was a real-life house of horrors. Both of them were physically beaten by Mitchell. They were regularly whipped with an extension cord and hit with a piece of wood.
她的惩罚是接受心理咨询。她被允许继续拥有孩子的监护权。作为调查的一部分，米歇尔的幸存子女接受了采访。他们详细描述了一个现实生活中的恐怖屋。他们两人都曾遭到米歇尔的身体虐待。他们经常被延长线抽打，并被木棍殴打。
Both had also been burnt with an iron. At the time they were taken by child services, both kids had numerous scars and injuries. Her son had 25 different scars on his back alone. There was clear medical evidence to back up their story that they were the victims of prolonged physical abuse from their mother. Mitchell was initially only charged with child abuse.
两人还都被熨斗烫伤过。当他们被儿童服务机构带走时，两个孩子身上都有无数的伤疤和伤痕。仅她儿子的背部就有25处不同的伤疤。有明确的医学证据支持他们的说法，即他们是母亲长期身体虐待的受害者。米歇尔最初只被控虐待儿童。
This was because the police had to wait for the results of the autopsy to determine exactly how the children died. And the autopsy was delayed as they had to allow the bodies to thaw out before it could be conducted. Mitchell was arraigned two days later, Thursday, the 26th of March. She was charged with four counts of first-degree child abuse,
这是因为警方必须等待尸检结果，以确定孩子们究竟是如何死亡的。尸检被推迟了，因为他们必须让尸体解冻后才能进行。米歇尔在两天后的3月26日星期四被提审。她被控四项一级虐待儿童罪，
which is punishable by 15 years in prison. She was also charged with one count of committing child abuse in the first degree in the presence of another child. That carries a life sentence. Her bond was set at $1 million. Within a week, the autopsies had been completed. The conclusion? There was no doubt. Stony Blair and Stephen Berry had been murdered.
最高可判处15年监禁。她还被控一项在另一名儿童在场的情况下实施一级虐待儿童罪。该罪名可判处终身监禁。她的保释金定为100万美元。一周内，尸检完成。结论是什么？毫无疑问。斯托尼·布莱尔和斯蒂芬·贝里是被谋杀的。
Mitchell's charges were upgraded to two counts of felony murder, two counts of premeditated murder, and one count of torture. Stephen Berry was killed around the 30th of August, 2012. Stony Blair was killed about nine months later, in May, 2013. Both had been left in the freezer
米歇尔的指控升级为两项重罪谋杀罪、两项蓄意谋杀罪和一项酷刑罪。斯蒂芬·贝里于2012年8月30日左右被杀。斯托尼·布莱尔在大约九个月后，即2013年5月被杀。两人都被留在冷柜里，
until the eviction crew found them in March, 2015. How didn't anybody notice Stony and Stephen missing? Well, some neighbours did notice that they hadn't seen them for a while, but when they asked the question, they believed Mitchell's story, that they spent a lot of time with an aunt, and when they were home, they didn't like to go outside. No alarm bells were raised at school
直到2015年3月被驱逐小组发现。为什么没有人注意到斯托尼和斯蒂芬失踪了？嗯，一些邻居确实注意到他们有一段时间没露面了，但当他们问起时，他们相信了米歇尔的说法，即他们和姨妈待在一起，而且当他们在家时，他们不喜欢出门。学校里没有拉响警报，
because they didn't go there in the first place. Their fathers hadn't seen them for several years, so they didn't notice either. Sadly, Stony and Stephen were able to go missing for two years, and nobody did anything other than ask a passing question as to where they were. Nobody asked any real questions or looked closely at all. They took an eviction crew to find them in the freezer
因为他们根本就没去上学。他们的父亲已经好几年没见过他们了，所以他们也没注意到。可悲的是，斯托尼和斯蒂芬失踪了两年，除了有人随口问一句他们在哪儿之外，没有人做任何事。没有人提出任何真正的问题或仔细观察。直到驱逐小组在冷柜里发现他们，
before anybody realised they were really gone. And the whole time the kids were in the freezer, Mitchell continued to accept government benefits for them. Mitchell was subjected to numerous evaluations by doctors and psychiatrists to make sure she was competent to stand trial and that she could be held criminally responsible for her actions. But Mitchell didn't want to wait for those reports.
大家才意识到他们真的不在了。在孩子们被关在冷柜里的整个过程中，米歇尔继续领取他们的政府救济金。米歇尔接受了医生和精神科医生的多次评估，以确保她有能力受审，并能为自己的行为承担刑事责任。但米歇尔不想等待那些报告。
She just wanted to plead guilty. She tried numerous times to plead guilty and have them finalised, but the court wouldn't allow it straight away. The court needed to make sure everything was done properly. They had possible future appeals in mind. They wouldn't accept the plea until all doctors' evaluations were officially announced.
她只想认罪。她多次尝试认罪并结案，但法院没有立即允许。法院需要确保一切程序合规。他们考虑到了未来可能出现的上诉。在所有医生的评估正式公布之前，他们不会接受认罪。
All doctors' evaluations were officially on record. My understanding to get a trial is to get to the truth, right? I'm already saying that I did it. I'm freely giving myself and accepting life in prison. If I'm already giving myself to you like, hey, I did this, what's the problem? And I'm not going to come back like, oh, I didn't understand my rights and I'm not a coward.
所有医生的评估都已正式记录在案。我的理解是，审判是为了寻求真相，对吧？我已经说了是我做的。我自愿认罪并接受终身监禁。如果我已经向你们坦白了，嘿，是我做的，那还有什么问题吗？我不会回头说，哦，我不明白我的权利，我不是懦夫。
You know what I'm saying? I don't have that second report from Dr. Shiner yet, okay? The forensics one is not good enough? No, that's why we requested an independent too, okay? Now, my understanding is that his evaluation is complete, but we just don't have it yet. These are some very serious charges and very... I understand all of them.
你知道我在说什么吗？我还没有收到沙纳（Shiner）医生的第二份报告，好吗？法医的那份还不够吗？不，这就是为什么我们也要求进行独立评估，好吗？现在，我的理解是他的评估已经完成，但我们还没拿到。这些是非常严重的指控，而且非常……我理解所有这些。
Give me an opportunity now. I profess three times. I understand. These are very serious charges with very serious consequences. If you were to plead guilty to a first-degree murder charge, that is life in prison without the possibility of parole. I know this. I'm happily saying life in prison,
现在给我一个机会。我说了三次了。我明白。这些是非常严重的指控，后果也非常严重。如果你对一级谋杀指控认罪，那就是终身监禁，不得假释。我知道这一点。我很高兴接受终身监禁，
if you had a death penalty, I would take that. I don't care. That's my baby, period. I'm not going to change my mind. I'm not changing anything. I don't need the week to think about it. When all doctors' reports were eventually placed onto the record, the court made a ruling that Mitchell was competent to stand trial,
如果你们有死刑，我会接受的。我不在乎。那是我的孩子，句号。我不会改变主意。我什么都不会改变。我不需要一周时间来考虑。当所有医生的报告最终被记录在案时，法院裁定米歇尔有能力受审，
and she could be held criminally responsible for her actions. As such, if she now wanted to plead guilty, the court would accept it. Mitchell wasn't insane. She knew exactly what she was doing and understood the consequences of her actions. Mitchell played guilty straight away. During her guilty plea, she described the how and why of what she did. Just a warning, the following clip is very graphic in detail
并且她可以为自己的行为承担刑事责任。因此，如果她现在想认罪，法院将予以接受。米歇尔没有精神错乱。她非常清楚自己在做什么，并理解自己行为的后果。米歇尔立即认罪。在认罪过程中，她描述了她所作所为的经过和原因。请注意，接下来的片段细节非常血腥，
that may not be suitable for all listeners. All right, Mr. Blair, we're here today because you've indicated that you want to plead guilty to two of the counts that are identified in the information since much of today's proceeding will be a dialogue between me and you. The first thing I'm going to do is swear you in. Do you solemnly swear or affirm that the testimony you're about to give today
可能不适合所有听众。好的，布莱尔女士，我们今天在这里是因为你表示想要对起诉书中指控的两项罪名认罪。由于今天的程序大部分将是你我之间的对话，我首先要做的是让你宣誓。你是否郑重宣誓或确认你今天即将提供的证词
will be the truth? Yes. Thank you. What is your name, ma'am? Mitchell Blair. Ms. Blair, how old are you? 36. Are you a United States citizen?
将是事实？是的。谢谢。女士，你叫什么名字？米歇尔·布莱尔。布莱尔女士，你多大了？36岁。你是美国公民吗？
Yes. Okay. Now, the information I have before me is that you want to plead guilty to count two, the premeditated murder of Stony Blair. Yes. And count three, the felony murder of Stephen Berry. Yes.
是的。好的。现在，我面前的信息显示，你想对第二项罪名，即蓄意谋杀斯托尼·布莱尔认罪。是的。以及第三项罪名，即重罪谋杀斯蒂芬·贝里认罪。是的。
Am I correct that you want to plead guilty to those counts? Yes. You understand that if I accept a guilty plea, you'll be subject to a mandatory sentence of life in the Michigan Department of Corrections without the possibility of parole for both cases. I understand. Do you understand Michigan does not have a death penalty?
我理解得对吗，你想对这些罪名认罪？是的。你明白如果我接受认罪，你将被判处密歇根州惩教署强制性的终身监禁，且不得假释，两起案件均是如此。我明白。你明白密歇根州没有死刑吗？
I do now. Okay. Ms. Blair, what did you do to Stony Blair that makes you guilty of premeditated murder? She raped my son. I intentionally killed her. How did you do that? Starting from the beginning,
我现在知道了。好的。布莱尔女士，你对斯托尼·布莱尔做了什么，导致你犯下了蓄意谋杀罪？她强奸了我的儿子。我蓄意杀死了她。你是怎么做的？从头说起，
when I found out about what Stony was doing to Matthew, it was nine months later after finding out about Stephen. So for the whole nine months, we were in the house. She was still raping my child. I did not know that. When I first found out after Matthew told me, I took a minute because I was not understanding, you know, that she did that to him.
当我发现斯托尼对马修（Matthew）所做的事情时，那是在发现斯蒂芬的事情九个月之后。所以在那九个月里，我们都在房子里。她一直在强奸我的孩子。我不知道。当我第一次从马修那里得知后，我花了一点时间，因为我不明白，你知道，她竟然对他做了那种事。
But I repeatedly punched her on many occasions. My son, I told him to tell me every single thing she did to him. So as she was telling me, he was telling me more and more things that she did. I assaulted her every time he told me what she did to him. By assault, I mean, I punched her. I have put a bag over her head until she lost consciousness. I threw hot water on her,
但我多次反复殴打她。我的儿子，我告诉他把她对他做的每一件事都告诉我。所以当她告诉我时，他告诉了我越来越多她做过的事。每次他告诉我她对他做了什么，我就殴打她。我所说的殴打，是指我揍她。我把袋子套在她头上直到她失去知觉。我往她身上泼热水，
scolding hot water from the faucet. Did you hit her in the head with a lipstick? Yes, I hit her in her head multiple times, over and over. Was that shortly before she died? That was actually the day before she died and the day she died. Okay. I hit on her back, like with her tailbone. I kicked her.
水龙头里滚烫的热水。你用口红打过她的头吗？是的，我多次打她的头，一遍又一遍。那是在她死前不久吗？那实际上是在她死的前一天和她死的那天。好的。我打她的背，比如尾骨部位。我踢她。
Okay, I just want to clarify a few things. And perhaps you don't know, but did this happen? Honor about May 25th, 2014? May 25th is actually the day she died. Well, the day I killed her. And you said you killed her by putting a grocery bag over her head? Yes. That day, Maddie would tell me different things
好的，我只是想澄清几件事。也许你不知道，但这发生在2014年5月25日左右吗？5月25日实际上是她死的日子。嗯，我杀死她的日子。你说你通过把购物袋套在她头上杀死了她？是的。那天，马修会告诉我不同的事情，
because she was doing this to him for years. And I did not know that. He gave what I'm saying and I didn't find out. 29 months later, she had started with Steven. She ruined my son. Okay. She started with Steven before he even started. So, yes, I put a bag over her head, but it got worse that day.
因为她多年来一直对他做这种事。而我不知道。他说了我所说的，但我没发现。29个月后，她开始对斯蒂芬下手。她毁了我的儿子。好的。她在斯蒂芬还没开始之前就对他下手了。所以，是的，我把袋子套在她头上，但那天情况更糟了。
Yes, I did. It got worse that day because Matthew would tell me how she would take her pad, her menstrual pad and squeeze her blood out in his mouth. Okay. And it was just, it was over with after that. It was over with. You meant to kill her? I definitely meant to kill her.
是的，我做了。那天情况更糟，因为马修会告诉我她是如何拿她的卫生巾，把血挤进他嘴里的。好的。在那之后一切就结束了。结束了。你是故意要杀死她吗？我绝对是故意要杀死她。
Okay. It wasn't an accident? No, not at all. If I had a chance to do it again, I would. When you went and got the grocery bag and suffocated her, that was your intention? Yes. She was standing in the bathtub.
好的。这不是意外？不，完全不是。如果我有机会再做一次，我还会这么做。当你去拿购物袋并让她窒息时，那是你的意图吗？是的。她当时站在浴缸里。
I was throwing hot water on her. My son was standing to my right outside the bathroom door and he was telling me, everything he was telling me, I looked at her and I'm like, you did this? And she was like, yes. So I actually had a stick and I was hitting her in the head. Every time he told me something, I hit her very hard in her head and I was throwing hot water on her.
我往她身上泼热水。我儿子站在我右边，浴室门外，他正在告诉我一切，我看着她，我说，你做了这些？她说，是的。所以我实际上拿了一根棍子，我用力打她的头。每次他告诉我什么，我就用力打她的头，并往她身上泼热水。
And when I actually took her out of the bathroom, I took her back in her room and I just kept staring at her and I said, she's my language, but I'm like, what the fuck would you do this to him? Just like, you know, I'm constantly asking her, she kept saying, I hate him. I'm like, you hate him? You know? And she admitted to me that she hated Gabrielle. She hated Stephen.
当我把她从浴室带出来，带回她的房间时，我一直盯着她看，我说，她是我的语言，但我当时想，你他妈为什么要对他做这种事？你知道吗，我一直在问她，她一直说，我恨他。我说，你恨他？你知道吗？她向我承认她恨加布里埃尔。她恨斯蒂芬。
She hated everybody. And I'm asking her why. She says, everybody always thinks Matthew's so cute. And I'm like, so you're like your brother because you get what I'm saying. So it's, I meant to. I definitely meant to. And I do not feel any remorse for what I did to Stony. Because she had no remorse for what she did to my son.
她恨所有人。我问她为什么。她说，每个人都觉得马修很可爱。我说，所以你就像你哥哥一样，因为你明白我的意思。所以，我是故意的。我绝对是故意的。我对斯托尼所做的一切没有任何悔意。因为她对我儿子所做的一切毫无悔意。
It's not only raped him, she gang raped him with Stephen. Matthew Ross sitting on the floor and he was telling me this how I found out about both of them doing it together. It was too late. Stephen was gone. But Matthew told me that Stony would actually make him sit there. Why? In his words, him and Stony, her and Stony did the nasty stuff.
她不仅强奸了他，还和斯蒂芬一起轮奸了他。马修·罗斯坐在地板上，他告诉了我这件事，我就是这样发现他们两个一起做这件事的。太晚了。斯蒂芬已经不在了。但马修告诉我，斯托尼实际上会让他坐在那里。为什么？用他的话说，他和斯托尼，她和斯托尼做了那些肮脏的事。
And then they did it to him. And now that's your way of inflicting punishment. Definitely. Okay. Okay. Where did that happen? What? Where did it?
然后他们对他做了。现在那是你施加惩罚的方式。当然。好的。好的。那是在哪里发生的？什么？在哪里？
The death. Her actual death? Yes. Um, I- Not the location of the house. Where did you live at the time? Oh, 8-0-4-10 on the street. Is that in the city of Detroit?
死亡。她真正的死亡？是的。嗯，我——不是房子的位置。你当时住在哪里？哦，街上8-0-4-10号。那是在底特律市吗？
Yes. You got her? Go ahead. Can you read it? Yes. Um, I swear if she ever actually saw or witnessed any of these acts with regard to Stony or Stony. Okay.
是的。你抓到她了吗？继续。你能读出来吗？是的。嗯，我发誓，如果她曾经亲眼看到或目睹了任何关于斯托尼或斯托尼的这些行为。好的。
Yeah. Did it- did you ever actually see anything of any sexual abuse of any kind between either Stephen and Stony and Matthew? I reject her question, but I will answer it because no one will say that this did not happen because it actually did. I just want to have a clear record. Because so far all you've told me was that you just heard it. Did you ever actually-
是的。你是否真的亲眼见过斯蒂芬、斯托尼和马修之间发生过任何形式的性虐待？我拒绝回答她的问题，但我会回答，因为没有人会说这没有发生，因为它确实发生了。我只是想留下清晰的记录。因为到目前为止，你告诉我的只是你听说过。你是否真的——
And that they admitted it. No, I did not. You get what I'm saying? Yeah. No, I understand. But as I went back in my head and thought back to all the many things that was wrong with Matthew over the years, and I'm like, that's what was wrong with you. He'll use the bathroom and say, mama, but it hurts my poop.
而且他们承认了。不，我没有。你明白我的意思吗？是的。不，我明白。但当我回想过去多年来马修身上出的所有问题时，我想，原来这就是你出的问题。他上厕所时会说，妈妈，但我拉屎很疼。
Oh, Matthew. So I started giving him 100% juice to make his stool softer, maybe to help me. But that wasn't the problem. It wasn't his stool. It was that he was being raped. Okay. My son looked me in my eyes and he gave me a very detailed account of everything they did.
哦，马修。所以我开始给他喝百分之百的果汁，让他的大便变软，也许能帮到我。但问题不在这里。不是他的大便问题。而是他被强奸了。好的。我儿子看着我的眼睛，非常详细地向我讲述了他们所做的一切。
Matthew is not a violent boy. He is a very sweet little boy. So for him to stand there and look at me and say, do it again, he was hurting. You know? Okay. At a certain point, I told him to stop talking. I said, Sony, you tell me what the fuck you did to my son. And I said, Matthew, if she's saying things that's not right, tell me.
马修不是一个暴力的男孩。他是一个非常甜美的小男孩。所以他站在那里看着我说，再做一次，他当时很痛苦。你知道吗？好的。在某个时刻，我让他别说了。我说，索尼，你告诉我你到底对我儿子做了什么。我说，马修，如果她说的不对，就告诉我。
She started telling me many things, many things. And I also asked her, so why didn't Stephen tell me that when I asked him, did anybody do this to him? Why didn't he tell me that you did it to him? Because Sony was going upstairs beating Stephen's ass, threatening him. Basically, at a certain point, after I was hitting Stephen, I didn't want to look at him. I didn't want to, I didn't want to look at him.
她开始告诉我很多事情，很多事情。我也问她，那么当我问斯蒂芬有没有人对他做过这种事时，他为什么不告诉我？他为什么不告诉我你对他做了这些？因为索尼当时正上楼去打斯蒂芬，威胁他。基本上，在我打了斯蒂芬之后，我不想看他。我不想，我不想看他。
So I told him to go to his room. When it came time to eat, I didn't want to take no food up. So I sent Sony up because she volunteered, not knowing at that time that Sony was raping either of them. But every time she went upstairs, I wouldn't have known if she hit him or not because I had put the Benny Bruises on him. So every time she went upstairs, she admitted to me that she was hitting him also, knocking the hell out of him, telling him, you better not tell her nothing.
所以我让他回房间。到了吃饭时间，我不想送饭上去。所以我让索尼上去，因为她主动请缨，当时我并不知道索尼在强奸他们中的任何一个。但每次她上楼，我都不知道她有没有打他，因为我已经教训过他了。所以每次她上楼，她都向我承认她也在打他，把他打得半死，告诉他，你最好什么都别告诉她。
Okay. Forget what I'm saying. I understand. When she admitted these things to you, were you always being physical with her? The first time, no, we were sitting there. Okay. She denied it, denied it, denied it constantly. I'm like, Sony, you better tell me if I can prove Matthew's sitting here.
好的。忘了我刚才说的。我明白。当她向你承认这些事情时，你总是对她动粗吗？第一次没有，我们当时坐在那儿。好的。她否认，一直否认，不断地否认。我说，索尼，如果我能证明马修坐在这里，你最好告诉我。
He don't know nothing about it. He constantly took, you get what I'm saying. Who would admit that? Who would admit that if they did not do it? Okay. All right. Tell me what happened to Steven. Basically the same thing.
他对此一无所知。他一直承受着，你明白我的意思吗。谁会承认呢？如果他们没做过，谁会承认呢？好的。好吧。告诉我史蒂文发生了什么事。基本上是一样的事情。
Can I ask you a question first? The people standing behind me, this woman who just asked the question, is she trying to make it seem like this did not happen? No, no, no. We just have to have a clear record. Okay. This is your time to talk. Go ahead.
我能先问你一个问题吗？站在我身后的人，刚才提问的那位女士，她是不是想让人觉得这事没发生过？不，不，不。我们只是需要一份清晰的记录。好的。现在是你说话的时间。请继续。
You're always trying to do it. Just make sure you don't do that kind of stuff. Okay. And so don't worry. The woman behind you, just do it. She actually did it. I mean, right now, man, this is just you choosing to plead guilty. The people did not have any sort of plea agreement.
你总是试图这样做。只要确保你别做那种事就行。好的。所以别担心。你身后的女士，尽管做吧。她确实做了。我是说，伙计，现在这只是你选择认罪。这些人没有任何认罪协议。
Yeah, because you know, it's like, I'm willing to take a polygraph test. It's like, because I understand people don't want to hear me, period, but I'm going to take it on everything. I'm listening to you. Tell me what happened to Steven. I came home one day. My daughter Gabrielle, my oldest, met me at the door and she's like, mom, come see what Maddie's doing with his dials.
是的，因为你知道，我愿意接受测谎仪测试。因为我明白人们根本不想听我说，但我愿意为一切接受测试。我在听你说。告诉我史蒂文发生了什么事。有一天我回到家。我大女儿加布里埃尔在门口迎接我，她说，妈妈，快来看看马迪在用他的玩偶做什么。
And I'm like, what is he doing? He was making one dial, his little wrestleman, hump on top of the other. No, I'm like, Maddie, why was you doing that? I said, anybody ever do this to you? He said, no. I said, then why are you doing that? And he said, yes, Steven did. And I was like, so this is the first I'm hearing about that period.
我问，他在做什么？他把一个玩偶，他的小摔跤手，骑在另一个上面。不，我说，马迪，你为什么要那样做？我说，有人对你做过这种事吗？他说，没有。我说，那你为什么要那样做？他说，是的，史蒂文做过。我当时想，这是我第一次听说这件事。
This was nine months before Stony. Okay. Stony wasn't downstairs. And she was always in the background. I wish to God I had questioned everybody together, but I didn't. Did you say this was around August 30th, 2012? No, this was before August 30th. August 30th is when he died.
这发生在斯托尼事件的九个月前。好的。斯托尼当时不在楼下。她总是在背景里。我真希望我当时把大家都叫到一起问清楚，但我没有。你说这大约是在2012年8月30日左右吗？不，这发生在8月30日之前。8月30日是他去世的日子。
Okay. This was maybe a week, a week and a half. Before he died. Yes. Okay. So that, Matthew telling you that set off some action? Yes. I went upstairs because Steven was upstairs in his and Matthew's room.
好的。这大概是在他去世前一周或一周半。是的。好的。所以，马修告诉你的这件事引发了什么行动吗？是的。我上楼了，因为史蒂文当时在他和马修的房间里。
And I went upstairs and I said, Steven. Matthew said you was humping on him. And then Steven stood up and he looked at me and right then I could tell. I could tell something was wrong in his face because he was just like this. Ain't no more kid. I know my kid would have been like, what? That's not what he did. He stood up and looked at me like he had lost his mind.
我上楼说，史蒂文。马修说你在骑他。然后史蒂文站起来看着我，就在那一刻我能看出来。我能从他的脸上看出不对劲，因为他当时就是那样。不再是孩子了。我知道我的孩子本该说，什么？他没做过那种事。他站起来看着我，就像丢了魂一样。
Okay. And it just hearing that from him had me fucked up in my head period. But I asked him, I said, Steven, tell me the fucking truth. What are you humping on Matthew? He said, yes, but that was all. And I said, did you hump on him with your underwear off? He said, no, Matthew yelled out, yes, he did. And I just remember going in the hallway, walking back and forth like, and I walked
好的。听到他这么说，我整个人都崩溃了。但我问他，我说，史蒂文，告诉我实话。你是不是在骑马修？他说，是的，但仅此而已。我说，你脱了内裤骑他了吗？他说，没有，马修大喊，是的，他脱了。我只记得走进走廊，来回踱步，然后我走开了。
back up and I was like, you fucked your brother. You fucked your brother. So I'm looking at them too. I'm looking at them like, what? I can't understand. So I started punching Steven. You know, I'm like, what the fuck are you doing to him? I just, I just started asking him questions.
退后，我当时想，你竟然对你弟弟下手。你竟然对你弟弟下手。所以我看着他们，我看着他们，心想，什么？我无法理解。所以我开始打史蒂文。你知道，我当时想，你对他做了什么？我只是，我只是开始问他问题。
Matthew at this point is just spilling out. He's just spilling out. And mom, and he's doing like this and he's doing this thing almost every night. He's telling me how he was. The reason I put bags over Steven's head is because if we had many, I thought many peed in the bed. My son was never a bad winner. Didn't know it was Steven waking up every morning, pissing on Matthew.
马修这时全招了。他全招了。还有妈妈，他几乎每天晚上都这么做。他告诉我他是怎么做的。我给史蒂文头上套袋子的原因是因为如果我们有马修，我以为马修尿床了。我儿子从来不是个输不起的人。我不知道原来是史蒂文每天早上醒来，尿在马修身上。
Like he was a damn piece of shit. Okay. They had bunk beds. Steven would get out the bed in the middle of the night. You would rape him in his own bed. You would pee on him instead of going to the bathroom. I'm waking up every morning thinking Matthew was a bad winner. So we just washed him up and going, you were a bad winner.
就像他是个混蛋一样。好吧。他们有上下铺。史蒂文会在半夜起床。你会在他自己的床上强奸他。你会在床上尿尿而不是去厕所。我每天早上醒来都以为马修是个输不起的人。所以我们只是帮他洗干净，然后说，你真是个输不起的人。
Let's talk about what you did to Steven. The reason I put bags over Steven's head, because my son told me that the plastic on his bed, because I thought he was a bad winner. He said, sometimes mom, I couldn't breathe. Steven was laying on me and he had my face down in the plastic on the bed. I couldn't breathe and he was humping on my butt like a basketball. That's when I got Garbage Bag and started putting it over Steven's head. And I started asking him, bitch, you know what I'm saying?
我们来谈谈你对史蒂文做了什么。我给史蒂文头上套袋子的原因，是因为我儿子告诉我床上的塑料布，因为我以为他是个输不起的人。他说，妈妈，有时候我无法呼吸。史蒂文压在我身上，把我的脸按在床上的塑料布里。我无法呼吸，他还在我屁股上像打篮球一样耸动。就在那时，我拿了一个垃圾袋，开始套在史蒂文头上。我开始问他，贱人，你知道我在说什么吗？
You see, this feel like you can't breathe. Stop it. That's my son. You could not breathe on top of getting ready. He was six years old at the time. You get what I'm saying? So I put a bag over his head. He lost consciousness.
你看，这种感觉就像你无法呼吸。住手。那是我儿子。你让他无法呼吸，还要准备对他下手。他当时才六岁。你明白我的意思吗？所以我往他头上套了个袋子。他失去了知觉。
I did that a couple of times. He told me that Mattie would be face down. He had stuff around his neck. So I grabbed Steven. I grabbed a belt and I put a belt around his neck and I lifted him up. Like, do you like how this feels? Me and choked with a belt. So I dropped him.
我那样做了几次。他告诉我马修会脸朝下。他脖子上缠着东西。所以我抓住了史蒂文。我拿了一条皮带，套在他的脖子上，把他提了起来。就像，你喜欢这种感觉吗？我用皮带勒住他。然后我把他扔下。
I held him up until he lost consciousness as well. You were intending to... No, I did not intend to kill Steven. No, no, no. I'm not... Listen to my question. You were intending to inflict serious physical harm but not killing him. Definitely.
我一直提着他直到他也失去了知觉。你的意图是……不，我没打算杀死史蒂文。不，不，不。我不是……听我的问题。你的意图是造成严重的身体伤害，但不是杀死他。当然是。
Okay. Did you also punch him? Yes, I did. Most of the time? Yes, I did. You talked about choking him. Did you also burn him? Yes, I did.
好吧。你还打了他吗？是的，我打过。大部分时间？是的，我打过。你提到了勒他。你还烧伤了他吗？是的，我烧过。
Okay, how did you do that? Hot water. Cold and hot water. Okay, again, you knew you were seriously harming him but you didn't intend to murder him. No. Okay. But your actions ultimately caused this down? Yes, they did.
好吧，你是怎么做的？热水。冷水和热水。好吧，再说一次，你知道你在严重伤害他，但你没打算谋杀他。没有。好吧。但你的行为最终导致了这一切？是的，确实如此。
Were you Steven's mother? Yes. He was in your custody? I don't claim him as my son now and I do not claim Stony as my daughter. I have two children. That's it. Steven and Stony are demons. Period.
你是史蒂文的母亲吗？是的。他在你的监护之下？我现在不承认他是我的儿子，我也不承认斯托尼是我的女儿。我有两个孩子。就这样。史蒂文和斯托尼是恶魔。句号。
Listen to my question. At the time he died, he was in your custody or care? Yes. How old was he? Steven was nine. And again, did this happen in your house in the city of Detroit? Yes. What you did to Steven was punishment for what you did to Maddie.
听我的问题。在他去世时，他在你的监护或照看之下吗？是的。他多大了？史蒂文九岁。再说一次，这发生在你们底特律的家里吗？是的。你对史蒂文所做的是对你对马修所做之事的惩罚。
Is that right? For what he did to Maddie. Oh, you're sorry? For what Steven did to you? Yes. That was punishment. And if I had killed Steven, intentionally I definitely would be proud to say I did. You weren't allowing them to treat your other children like that's for you?
是这样吗？因为他对马修所做的。哦，你很抱歉？因为史蒂文对你所做的？是的。那是惩罚。如果我故意杀了史蒂文，我绝对会为自己所做的感到自豪。你没有允许他们那样对待你的其他孩子？
What do you mean? You weren't allowing them to sexually assault. No, I wasn't allowing that. I did. I never knew. Did you hear what I'm saying? That's exactly what I wanted to know. You didn't know until afterwards.
你是什么意思？你没有允许他们进行性侵犯。不，我没有允许。我做了。我从来不知道。你听到我在说什么了吗？那正是我想要知道的。你直到事后才知道。
So, man, I don't regret. None of this. I don't regret any of it. Matthew was my son. That's my baby. It's no way that his brother and sister should know what he feels like inside. It's no way. Understood.
所以，伙计，我不后悔。这一切我都不后悔。马修是我的儿子。那是我的宝贝。他的兄弟姐妹绝不应该知道他内心的感受。绝不可能。明白了。
I don't feel no remorse for the death of them demons. Okay. All right. I'm going to accept the plea unless either counsel is satisfied with the testimony that was just provided by Ms. Blair. I believe there was a sufficient actual basis to accept the plea at this point. Her claims that both Stoney and Steven were sexually assaulting her youngest son were never substantiated.
对于这些恶魔的死，我没有任何悔意。好吧。好的。除非任何一方律师对布莱尔女士刚才提供的证词感到满意，否则我将接受认罪协议。我相信目前有充分的事实依据来接受认罪。她声称斯托尼和史蒂文性侵了她最小的儿子，这些说法从未得到证实。
The reason she says she reacted so violently was that she herself was sexually assaulted when she was younger. She reported the assault to her mom and her mom failed to do anything about it. Her mother's failure to protect her affected her for the rest of her life. It led her to tell her own kids that if anybody ever touched them to tell her about it straight away so she could do something. When the youngest son reported to her that he was assaulted by Stoney and Steven, she reacted.
她说她反应如此激烈的原因是她自己年轻时曾遭受过性侵。她向她妈妈报告了这次袭击，但她妈妈什么也没做。她母亲未能保护她，影响了她的一生。这导致她告诉自己的孩子，如果有人碰他们，要立刻告诉她，这样她就能采取行动。当最小的儿子向她报告说他被斯托尼和史蒂文侵犯时，她做出了反应。
Alexander Dorsey was the father of Stoney Blair and the surviving 17-year-old girl. He hadn't seen either of his children for two years prior. He says that Mitchell barred him from the home. He had a prior criminal history and he actually owed $39,000 in child support. It was deemed that he failed to protect the children from an unfit home environment where the children were physically abused, tortured and murdered. It was not only our custody of his surviving daughter. Stephen Berry Sr. was the father of Stephen Berry and to the surviving 8-year-old boy.
亚历山大·多尔西是斯托尼·布莱尔和幸存的17岁女孩的父亲。他在那之前的两年里没见过他的任何一个孩子。他说米切尔禁止他进入家中。他有犯罪前科，实际上还欠了39,000美元的子女抚养费。法院认为他未能保护孩子免受不健康的家庭环境影响，孩子们在那里遭受了身体虐待、折磨和谋杀。他不仅失去了幸存女儿的监护权。史蒂文·贝里高级是史蒂文·贝里的父亲，也是幸存的8岁男孩的父亲。
He last saw his children three years prior. He also says that Mitchell prevented him from seeing them. He owed $10,000 in child support payments. He also had a criminal record and it was also deemed that he neglected to protect his children from an abusive environment. He was not awarded custody either. Both surviving children lived in absolute terror and will need extensive trauma therapy and counselling.
他最后一次见到孩子是在三年前。他也说米切尔阻止他见他们。他欠了10,000美元的子女抚养费。他也有犯罪记录，也被认为疏于保护孩子免受虐待环境的影响。他也没有获得监护权。两个幸存的孩子生活在极度的恐惧中，将需要大量的创伤治疗和咨询。
The 8-year-old boy was displaying problems with his neurological development due to the horror he experienced every day. Although Alexander Dorsey was not awarded custody, unlike Stephen Berry Sr. he actually retained his parental right and the judge did this for good reason. If he removed Dorsey's parental right then his daughter would only qualify for services until she was 19 years old. But by keeping Dorsey's parental right intact, she qualifies for services until she is 20. By services they are talking about helping her go to college, classes to teach her to
那个8岁的男孩由于每天经历的恐怖，表现出了神经发育方面的问题。虽然亚历山大·多尔西没有获得监护权，但与史蒂文·贝里高级不同，他实际上保留了他的父母权利，法官这样做是有充分理由的。如果他剥夺了多尔西的父母权利，那么他的女儿将只能获得服务到19岁。但通过保留多尔西的父母权利，她可以获得服务到20岁。所谓服务，是指帮助她上大学，教她
live independently and obviously therapy. The court ruled it would be in her best interest to qualify for these services for an extra year. She mentioned that she wanted to go to college and become a veterinarian. The judge said it would be totally up to her what sort of relationship, if any, she wanted to have with Dorsey. Michelle Blair's parental rights to her two surviving children were terminated. She was sentenced on the 17th of July 2015. Despite what happened to you when you were a child, you had the opportunity to grow up.
独立生活的课程，当然还有治疗。法院裁定，让她多获得一年的这些服务符合她的最大利益。她提到她想上大学并成为一名兽医。法官说，她想与多尔西建立什么样的关系（如果有的话）完全取决于她自己。米歇尔·布莱尔对她两个幸存孩子的父母权利被终止。她于2015年7月17日被判刑。尽管你小时候遭遇了什么，你还是有机会长大的。
True. You had the opportunity to become an adult. You had the opportunity to make your own decisions with respect to running your own life. And you were blessed with four children. Stormy and Stephen aren't ever going to have that. They don't have those same opportunities. And when I think about all of the possible joys that they could be missing out on, one thing that strikes me as the greatest tragedy here is that they will never know what a life is like
没错。你有机会成为成年人。你有机会在经营自己生活方面做出自己的决定。你有幸拥有四个孩子。斯托尼和史蒂文永远不会有那样的机会。他们没有同样的机会。当我想到他们可能错过的所有快乐时，我认为这里最大的悲剧是他们永远不会知道生活是什么样的
without experiencing, fearing their mother. They will never know the joy of what could have been in their life without having you in it. They lived in terrible fear of you. And I find that just so sad in this case. After all of a sudden done, you imposed the death penalty on your own children. I did. And you readily admit it, and you want to take responsibility of it. You're therefore sentenced to the Michigan Department of Corrections for the rest of your life without possibility of parole,
而不用经历恐惧他们的母亲。他们永远不会知道没有你在他们生命中，生活本可以有的快乐。他们生活在对你的极度恐惧中。我觉得这个案子太令人悲伤了。归根结底，你对你自己的孩子执行了死刑。我执行了。你欣然承认，并且你想为此承担责任。因此，你被判处在密歇根州惩教署服刑余生，不得假释。
meaning of course that you will never get out. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当然意味着你永远无法离开。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。